لا شيء الا القتال في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وفي دارفور غربي البلاد فمع توقف
الهدى على ما لزمها من انتهاكات من قبل
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع المتمرده بوصف
القوات المسلحه عادت المواجهات على اكثر
من جبهه في مدن العاصمه الثلاث
ففي جنوب الخرطوم تدور معارف عنيفه بين
الجيش وبين قوات الدعم السريع في منطقه
مستودعات الوقود هل تمت امل لهدنه اخرى في
اتصال وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن
فرحان بالفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان قائد
الجيش ورئيس مجلس السياده ما يشيء
بامكانيه بحث موضوع الهدنه مره اخرى لكن
البرهان الذي اكد ثقته في منبر جده طلب
بضروره التزام قوات الدعم السريع بالخروج
من المستشفيات والمراكز الخدميه ومنازل
المواطنين واخلاء الجرحى وفتح مسارات
تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
اذا كان لمنبر جده اي يحقق اي نجاح في
التعاطي مع الازمه اما وان الهدنه لا تلوح
بعد في الافق فيبدو ان الجيش ماض في صديقه
الخناق على قوات الدعم السريع التي قتل
عدد كبير من افرادها واستسلم منهم مثلهم
لكن قوه منهم لا تزال موجوده في اكبر
قواعدهم واكثرها تحصيلا وهي قاعده طيب
الحسنه جنوب الخرطوم بنحو عشرين كيلو مترا
اما بقيه قوات الدعم السريع فهي منتشره
منذ بدايه القتال في شوارع الخرطوم وتتخذ
من الاحياء السكنيه ملاذات امنه تصعب مهمه
ضربها من قبل الجيش
لكنه وجود اخذ في التناقص من جراء ما تلقت
من ضربات يقول الجيش انها دمرت مقرها وشلت
مركز القياده والسيطره لديها خاصه بعد
غياب قائدها المثير للتكه نات رغم
التاكيدات اخيه انه في قياده المعركه
الحمد لله بكل امن وامان والان في الصفوف
الاماميه مع قواته والانسان
وشقيقه قد دخل هذه الحرب من اجل ما يقولان
انها حرب من اجل المدنيه والديمقراطيه
فالراجح انما اتهم به سلوك قوات الدعم
السريع من عنف تجاه المواطنين رجالا ونساء
واتجاه الاسرى يضرب مشروع المدنيه فضلا عن
الديمقراطيه في مقتل
في مدينه الجنينه غربي دارفور تدور رحى
حرب اخرى ربما لا مزاعم لها في
الديمقراطيه او الحكم المدني الذي طلبه
حميد تل الخرطوم انها حرب تاخذ بعدا قبليا
اثنيه
ارتفع عدد القتلى خلال الاسابيع الثلاثه
الماضيه الى اكثر من 500 قتيل واكثر من
الف مصاب ودفع القتال ما يزيد على 100 الف
من المواطنين الى اللجوء الى تشاد هذا
بالاضافه الى الاف النازحين داخل السودان
سفك الدماء في الخرطوم اليوم وسفكها اليوم
وامسك الاطراف يبدو لكثيرين ليس تعبيرا عن
عنف متاصل في الشعب السوداني بمقدار تاصله
في بؤس السياسه والسياسيين قبل الثوره
وبعدها وليس العسكر من ذلك براء